hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to fire watch this game just
came out very recently and apparently we
see julia hi Julia oh she's about your
age late 20s laughing with well-dressed
professors and grad students from nearby
cu-boulder
you Henri around drinking with you pals
you approach er you are drunk
oh ok so I get to choose you yeah you're
pretty you're pretty
she says coolly you are not you're a
future hangover plus you reply confuse
someone should buy you a cheeseburger
she says she Flags down a waiter in one
week later you and you are Julia's
boyfriend one week
things are moving quite fast don't you
think oh ok so this game I saw was
released on Steam it was suggested to me
and it had a lot of really gorgeous
visuals and very interesting artistic
design you may not have seen it with
that opening in the text obviously but
you'll see it in a little bit here
there's a lot of interesting things to
this one even though I have no idea what
this game is about or what to do with
this game it has to do with obviously
being in the park and watching for
fliers you date for over a year she
drives you absolutely nuts it's great
it's great ok that sounds so great you
move in you share an apartment near the
school with a few of the mountains you
too drink beers out on the deck you
drink beer just about anywhere so you're
a raging alcoholic life is good alright
Julie wants to get the dog yes I agree
Julia sounds awesome there's a scruffy
undersized beagle Julie is in love she
wants to bring it with her to class
there's also an intimidating but gentle
a German Shepherd nothing bad could
happen to julia while the dog walking
with his dog it's badass oh oh what a
choice I love beagles but German
Shepherds LEGOs a German Shepherd he's a
little intimate
looking Oh me me mayhem Oh cool name
I gotta go with the Shepherd Mayhem's an
excellent dog he loves wrestling with
you in the park and goes with Juliana
runs even though he's too big to bring
to school Julia loves him all the same
mayhem is a friend child and pet all
rolled into one
oh I completely agree chica and Lego
1979 you talk out on the deck it's
summer 9:30 p.m. and the heat still
radiates off of the high desert what do
you think about kids she asks Oh getting
serious here kids they're not very smart
or good at much I'm saying if you and I
have some a couple little idiots let's
see one day why rush oh you know what
these two seem like they're moving
quickly so why not just rush headlong
into an obligation that's gonna tie you
down for the rest of your life in that
case we should probably get married yeah
I would like that you say these kids are
gonna be screwed up enough it's probably
for the best that the parents are
hitched you say she's absolutely right
oh that's what I was talking about just
look at this I was watching the trailer
and I was reading I was looking at the
screenshots it's just gorgeous learn to
live with bears do not forget to check
in no fireworks their affair trail is
not recommended from inexperienced
hikers okey-dokey men oh it's freakin
beautiful and I love this style
all right let's wander out into the
woods I really wonder like it's an odd
juxtaposition of the storytelling in
this element of it and I know they're
gonna be intertwined soon enough it's a
Thursday night and Julia is four hours
late she doesn't call you're worried and
getting angrier by the minute she walks
in after you've gone to bed she's not
quite drunk but she's clearly been
having a fun time you fight when she
gets between the sheets you get matter
you ignore both not the right option you
talk about things you know communicate
like adults
oh I guess I give her the cold shoulder
oh I'm not talking to you you don't
touch each other all night the next day
you feel guilty for being so angry and
asked her about her evening she says it
was great you hold on to a tiny pill of
resentment he'd make some coffee and go
to work oh man I knew they were just
setting this up so it would fall down
Julie still likes to draw she draws
plants from her research she draws all
the places you go she draws you you pose
and flex like he-man are you frolic like
a victorious in you hell yeah Victoria's
Secret model all the way I love a good
frolic julia was right you are very
pretty
hope to hell oh did I just break my
kneecaps open I don't know where I'm
going kinda reminds me of slender but
then again every time I'm in the woods I
say that so maybe I should get a new
thing to remind me of things about but
when it's such a big part of my history
of playing games it's hard not to
remember that was that say two forks
fire look out eight miles ahead okay
that's probably good because I imagine
that's where I'm trying to go I still
don't know how this forest move gorgeous
oh so pretty
1982 during the summers you and Julia
enjoy walking mayhem at night oh oh
sorry sorry there's a festival in town
it brings in folks from faraway places
one of them tries to mug you with a
knife well that took a drastic turn
mayhem runs away may mibu [ __ ] the dog
julia yells she gets flustered in house
trouble speaking when she's stressed you
confront the attacker Oh
mayhem runs away you beat his goddamn
face it ah how am I gonna scare him away
I'm gonna scare him away
whoa you reach into your pocket like you
got a gun threatened to kill him you
managed to scare all three of you he
runs away Julie asks to take a different
path from that day forward you say okay
you
want to go that way either from then on
you walked by the river Oh a different
path what oh okay I got you okay that
makes where I was like I thought who's
like the relationship take a different
path plans to have kids get waylaid by
work Julia gets offered a job at Yale
Yale is in Connecticut 2,000 miles away
it's a great job associate department
chair she wants to move you absolutely
do not agree if she commutes back at
work she commutes back in for if these
are not good compromises these are not
compromises here commute 2,000 miles
that's terrible and I can't convince her
not to take the job cuz that would be
ridiculous that's that's not good for me
it's a good job for her this is not
alright commute I can't I can't tell her
not to follow her dreams that's just
terrible
you ask her if she'll commute back and
forth you don't want to move to
Connecticut
she says that'll be hard but she'll do
it if you won't move I'll move this guy
won't move you tell her not to pass it
up if it's you it's what she wants okay
that's good she flies back to Boulder
three times each semester damn
Julia's sent home from Yale on paid
leave after having an episode she lost
it on a colleague for borrowing books
that were important to her research she
didn't remember she had happily loaned
them to him just two days prior she was
found crying in the stairwell you say
that maybe you guys should talk about to
someone about it
you make macaroni and drink one and try
to forget about it see that's option a
is handling it like an adult
macaroni and wine don't solve problems
I'm gonna go with the left option after
seeing multiple doctors and having many
tests they are worried that Julia might
be suffering from early onset dementia
she's 41 you both decide to keep it a
secret from now goodness gravy this took
a turn this took quite a turn
oh man mayhem is getting older he's got
silver hair down his back and slows down
at night you and Julia walk him to the
bar to see your friends it feels like
nothing's changed
Julia goes back to the University all
right then Julia's affliction gets worse
she can't remember things in her class
her research is in shambles she drives
her car to the next town over for no
particular reason and has to be brought
home by the police she's devastated
she's sent home on permanent medical
leave some days you get the Julia who
calls you a dope and your unborn
children little idiots of the days you
get a stranger she pulls you into bed to
make love after five minutes she goes
into a panic believing her dad is at the
door he'd tell her family they're
crushed and begin to make trips to and
from their home in Australia to visit
her for a while your friends come by
with little things to brighten the day
she gets worse oh my god you spend your
days following Julia around the house
you count the seconds between the two
weekly visits from Daniel the nurse he
suggests that Julia could live somewhere
else
someone with 24-hour care a home it sits
with you for a couple months you decide
to move her into a full-time care
facility or you determined to take care
of her advise herself okay this is
actually something that hits home to me
because when my stepdad had his accident
like he's currently in a home but like
there was a spell of time when we had to
take care of him by ourselves and that's
hard like that is hard hard work because
there were team as he was so disabled
that he you know he couldn't even go to
the bathroom for himself you know he
couldn't get food he couldn't he could
barely feed himself so taking care of
someone like that is more work than
anyone could possibly imagine
you almost can't do that by yourself but
like then again being through that if
this was my wife and this was someone
that I really loved I would do that I
would drop everything to take care of
him by myself even if I had to I mean
it's very expensive to put someone into
a home
so yeah it's the only choice I could
make okay where am I oh it was gonna go
down automatically all right then
who can I not jump down that I wonder if
he even liked walking through this
forest as a choice and I wonder how much
the choices that I made so far kind of
affect the world that I've been in if it
actually is affecting it and that being
said I don't oh look it's a deer that
distracts me from my problems for a
little bit hello hi friend
how you doing okay then don't get stiffy
with me I don't even know what stiffy
means it is impossibly hard the worst is
when you get mad at her like when she
tries to cook her own food you can't do
anything without her and she can't do
anything without you
yep that's I know that I know that
personally it's it's impossibly hard a
great way to describe it when she goes
to sleep you stay up for a few hours
drinking on the deck watching baseball
in the summer college basketball in the
winter drinking then - I was joking
about alcoholism before you start going
out after he put her to bed the first
time you do it you worry about her
getting up and walking around while
you're gone you just put it shared would
lock her in you trust that she sleeps
like both of these are bad options
you can't lock her in there that's
terrible
but I guess logically it's better than
just going like ah she's probably fine
that's so horrible what joy what kind of
choices are those ah you go to the same
bar at the boring end of Pearl Street
it's nice there over time you tell
Sheila the bartender everything it's a
huge weight off your home and in bed by
1:00 a.m. a couple nights a week you
look forward to those nights
Oh God one night you're stopped at a DUI
checkpoint you blow a point ten and are
taken to jail for the night you consider
trying to hide it but you tell your
sister lost Susan Julia's parents take
the next plane from Australia they can't
believe the state your house is in then
they tell you julia is coming to live
with them you don't argue you say you'll
visit soon a few weeks go by summer is
coming and you see an ad in the paper
for a job you take it and is that where
the game begins
and they're the lookout - oh my god that
was just a prologue thoroughfare look at
all it's assigned in the way oh my god
getting vibes from freaking up until
dawn that's pretty sad this this took a
turn like I didn't expect there's
absolutely bonkers just like a lot of
things that come with the art of games
comes from like the storytelling and
stories can be told in an unlimited
number of ways there's no there's no
rules for telling a story and this is
one choice that I haven't actually
encountered much of and god that is
gorgeous and it's gorgeous because it's
stylized and that's like it's
interesting let me just take a quick
peek around and when I encounter a game
like this that does have a lot of
different elements about storytelling
and it tells it in a very unique way and
it kind of gives a different view of
everything that could be seen like from
this character's eyes because especially
when it comes to storytelling games it's
about seeing things from the character's
eyes and knowing their perspective while
also not saying that you have to be that
character and you have to feel with that
you don't have to feel with the
character but well hello I'll get back
to that in a second as soon as I gather
my
thoughts untapped power in my own mind
okie-dokie them am I gonna start fires
with my mind oh sorry I just wanted to
throw that rage no you don't know what
are you talking about all right
hello fine I got it
I'm on it just took me a little brain
power to figure out how to do that how
do I reply left shift activate the radio
hello
I guess hello hello whoever this is oh
yeah yeah that's what the guy said on
the phone with you
look I just hiked for two days so I
don't really follow whatever it is
you're doing right now fine then can I
sleep forever you've killed three
ex-husbands you're rebelling against mom
nobody back home can stand you yeah
that's kind of the one that I picked
probably out here because nobody back
home can stand you which after this
brief introduction is not a big shock
well I better get some sleep then it's
my turn okay
you just really like trees that's
amazing
language lady out your west facing
window that's not legal right through
the [ __ ] roof is that really my job
whatever I say it is the closest Ranger
is like two days away go down there and
straight you know what for lady I kick
the [ __ ] out of them like kick the [ __ ]
out of them sort of straight what I'm
not a cop it's not like I've got a
rulebook over here
sure they don't do it again take their
[ __ ] alright fine
don't feed anyone a knuckle sandwich hey
between you and the lake if I remember
right the supply box on the way the code
is one two three four actually oh okay
is it on the road smart
we're having a sassy dynamic
relationship here okay so what I was
saying before about everything is just
just to summarize all my thoughts before
and I can't quite remember exactly what
I was saying before but it's interesting
to see a unique choice and storytelling
like this and that's all I'll say for it
on the matter now I gotta go deliver a
knuckle sandwich to someone out on the
under way
so we're that I need to go west I need
to go west
I'm gonna show these bastards what for
oh my god it's beautiful
its glorious out can I talk to you
Delilah Delilah I want to improve our
relationship I want to give a few points
in empathy towards you and towards me
because of all the things that I've had
to deal with in my life with Julia I
mean I know that's gonna come up because
obviously everything that was talked
about before was just to get backstory
to these characters and see how this
plays out and admittedly very different
than what I was thought it was gonna be
because when I saw this game I thought
that maybe like maybe the actual game
was just gonna be about wandering around
the forest and putting out fires hence
the name of the game but I should have
assumed a little more about the game
because I've been playing a lot of indie
games so I don't expect things to be
more deep than their face value hello
I've got it I found the supply box okay
cool thanks buddy okay so one two three
fear got it thank you
so that's it to all of them is that good
okay so I can mark down is that Future
cast locations or something all right
Ron hey man guy couldn't take it so I
locked up his
look out and put some stuff in the box
found one of those bars you liked hiking
in the park but let's get [ __ ] when
I'm back ok cool a bar is it filled with
weed ok good broken granola bar is this
going to get me [ __ ] up
probably not it's nutrition put it in
her face there we go so I can hopefully
that didn't that wasn't infused with
super weave juice okay let me get my map
back out define who's setting off these
fireworks god damnit smokey the bear
didn't die for this smokey the Bears
still around I mean he's a fictional
character so obviously talking jogging
what oh I can jog okay that's good
I guess our four run I mean I know
smokey is a fictional character but
mayhaps they may have retired him at
some point because I haven't seen the
PSA from a long time even though
everyone probably still knows Smokey
Bear this better be someone in a
life-or-death situation because I've got
to knuckle sandwiches that are ready for
punishment hey there's a tree out here
that's been ripped to hell
don't you think that's you know like
disconcerting we don't have Grizzlies in
Colorado people killed them a long time
ago don't you think that's disconcerting
this wouldn't be so bad but I probably
need to get away back how do I attach
group only attached rope how do I attach
rope I want to attach rope let me attach
a rope noticin documents
inventory nope rope you give rope put
Rob on thing there we go
I needed to put it on the other side I'm
a free
idiot I don't know what I'm doing with
my life you bastards I'm coming to get
you
I've got muscles out the ass and the
sass of a Victoria's Secret model let's
show you what for I get down there
imagine the fire go cat ow
well that broke my entire spine
shattered in 10,000 places you say oh
and my arms and legs too I'll never walk
again
great okay I think I'm fine my rope
snapped coming down the shale slide no I
think I'll make it okay chrissake
four critic Kerr FERC for kohsaka be
careful old climbing gear huh okay I
need to report this hey there's a tie
off point off here just a little away
from the shale slide I can't go any
further is what I'm saying
okay thanks Delilah I mean I actually
know a friend that hasn't the has a job
like this my friend Michelle she
actually came out to California to work
in the woods like this she was here
originally because she was working on
some trail maintenance stuff and then
she hurt her knee but then she came back
out again for something else that I have
no idea but she disappears into the
weeks into the woods for weeks at a time
and just kind of the way
it is a hell of a nice camping spot down
here by the lake is perfect
oh I'm so responsible look at me I'm
recycling look at me no no no come on
come on with that attitude you're never
gonna save the entire environment we're
hugging trees left and right here where
am I putting him anyway
I'm just shoving him up my anus to store
for laters until I can throw him away
that was a funny joke that was a funny
joke markiplier you never really send
the bar for humor here yep it looks like
there's yeah I just found where they're
hanging out what a bunch of losers
coming out into the woods and having a
good time finding a bunch of empty beer
cans they threw them all over hell
screaming all right I guess I got a free
license to knuckle sandwich to
everything ferret are Irish they left
half a bottle of whiskey decent stuff
safe for later haha and I thought I
wouldn't be able to entertain my ramp
and Alcoholism here huh take some of
that that's just half the justice that
I'm gonna deal out to those [ __ ]
down by the creek oh and there's skinny
dipping to let the clothes out to dry it
looks like two people
something's gonna go horribly wrong here
this can't be an exact Forest Lake
maintenance guy simulator because
there's got to be oh no they are naked
oh the horror
uh-huh no I'm not gonna remain
professional this would look great on me
later oh great
this is just lovely oh why did I drop
those but you drop those but I took the
bra with me oh no I dropped the borrow
bra - I'm not a complete pervert oh
nothing to report yet just music oh boy
there are two naked ladies out here can
you handle that come on
I like naked ladies same as anyone but
there's you know I don't know I don't
know well I'll just have to deal with
this mano a mano
I've still got the knuckles Sam oh look
pick up just hold it over my head Pele's
Oh was it
okay yeah that could have turned out
wonderfully for you this is being
randomly in the woods and naked blasting
music so anybody and bears would be able
to know where you are great job ladies
nope
I hope they drown it went fine there
just in case I totally forgot that that
might be copyrighted music in hi I
wouldn't be able to put that part in oh
I hope that's okay I mean I could have
delivered their underwear to them I
suppose but I mean I guess this is
1980-something so it's still a while ago
not that like people don't go
skinny-dipping nowadays I'm just saying
that went rather well for a little
adventure being stupid out naked stupid
and naked out in the woods how could
they those evil people and now I gotta
go all the way back home a lot of burden
this would actually be really cool if I
was able to go out in the woods and had
enough time that I wouldn't have to make
youtube videos for the entire time that
I was out there not sure how to get back
what Weston the north towards the canyon
how am I supposed to be able okay so I
got to get back towards the lake in the
north towards the canyon is that gonna
be like this path over here and how
would that take me back to where I need
to go okay I'm not I'll be right back if
I could
lost here oh okay we're fine we're good
we're good we're good we know we're
going we got this hundred percent okay
Oh
[Music]
he's got a weed bar I'm gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of him is this some sort of
code I missed are we evacuating or
something I think Delilah has gone stir
crazy out in the woods all by herself so
she doesn't have anybody to keep her
company so she's got to take out all of
her pent-up loneliness on me which is
just sad
not that I'm lonely being alone in my
room recording videos for other people
to enjoy I don't think this is the way
that I was supposed to go all righty
then
I'm circled back completely asinine in
Italy and apparently I was supposed to
stay down there okay I was in such a
hurry to run away from the copyrighted
music so there are just two naked girls
running around in the middle of the
woods that doesn't not seem safe oh okay
got it this way whoa okay so where we
headed now in this Oh River nice this is
probably gonna trigger some memories for
me I wonder how this is gonna turn out
what's over there wait okay which way
should I go here I could either go that
way or continue along the canyon river
route oh I think I see something over
there nope I see nothing okay I'm gonna
go this way I'm gonna see what's up here
if I miss something over there then
that's just too bad because I've made my
choice and I'm sticking with it yeah but
if I be
actually I went looking for the job I
just wanted to get out of town for a
while mm-hmm you've come to the right
place thanks to last summer we got a
bump in Forest Service budget and can
actually afford to have you oh cool
that's nice let me just crack open the
safe and steal everything that's inside
I hope it's weed no I need to I need to
reply ah what happened last summer that
accounted for this 15 miles away why
would they do that story is that for 60
years we got very good at not letting
forest fires happen about 15 years ago
they decided that forest fires and
wilderness areas like should be left to
burn so that's what they did
damn I had no idea about that you know
there's so many things that happen in
the world that you just don't know about
because they're not very reported not
written in Colorado I really don't think
there is right and then put it on a
sweatshirt okay maybe I'm in some
alternate reality there was a book that
said something about the power of my
mind and if I know anything about this
character I'm a big smarty and I might
be the best ever
well this Lake does seem like a good
spot to swim even if the last people to
do so were [ __ ]
maybe that's a fair trade starting to
feel like it mmm even hollowing those
naked ladies running all about it okay
I'm a weird pervert
I'm modeling Victoria Secret clothes
don't mind me I'm just an old hermit in
the woods and I don't think I'll be able
to go down there so I must need to go
down along the river path because that's
the only way to go Anisa need to get
back to my hidey hole if I can get back
to my heart hole then everything is
gonna be a-okay there's something
peaceful about being in the woods
because me and my brother when we were
kids and I said this in my draw my life
of course but one me and my brother were
very young in the backyard of the house
that we had growing up there was an
entrance into the woods and obviously
these weren't incredible woods these
were just you know rural area woods you
know not exactly incredibly forested but
that's a lot of what Ohio will do and by
the way we can be alcoholism buddies
because me to do that thing with the
drink and do and you do also will do
thank you I'm safe it's not gonna strike
twice remember that I don't like the
sound of that
yeah anyway so when me and my brother
were kid we'd go out in the woods all
the time and we just explore like back
area there it was just incredibly fun
because to us as little kids that
those woods were huge we could walk
there for an hour straight just walking
down the creek and it would never end it
and like to us that was like
immeasurably big that was like walking
across the nation you know we'd say like
and you know so we had a great time
doing that okay does that mean it was
shut it off for someone's poaching out
here anyway so me and my brother used to
go caving with someone back in Colorado
she loved it might be great to explore
it sometime this summer very careful
with someone down here it doesn't seem
that danger seriously it's completely
fine in here or best of friends we're
fast friends play with the caves echo
[Music]
this cave has gated off it's to stop
spelunkers from dying without getting
the keys from the Forest Service office
first makes sense
debbie says she lost him like three
years ago so maybe its mysteries are
locked away for good
damn it Debbie hot damn damned this
one's so close to home and convenient
though come on mommy
I just wanna go spelunking I just wanna
Splunk oh that looks bad that's probably
gonna kill me if the Bears don't least I
got this flashlight so when we were
walking around in the woods it was just
endless endless woods and we did so many
things back there like just a huge part
of my childhood is walking around in the
[Laughter]
Whooper the fun also being stabbed
multiple times with a spoon very fun I'm
a boss on the beast and the best I'm an
Olympic jumper you didn't know
professionally jumping for 23 years
anyway so when we round the woods leg it
was total freedom and that was one of
the great things about it just utter
freedom we were able to go wherever you
want you're able to do pretty much
whatever you want to nature as much as
little kids could dude to nature which
was mostly just like diverting like
creek beds and like like being horrible
we were practically eco-terrorists to
the life that was in that creek because
we would take frogs and stuff and we'd
wait until they laid their eggs and you
know we'd like section off parts of the
creek and
because we were trying to think like oh
we just wanted to like you know create
our own little like lake area with life
in it we wanted the tadpoles to hatch
and be safe but what we inadvertently
did was trap them make sure they didn't
get fresh water and then died and there
were like a pool right there full of
tadpoles so that other creatures could
eat him right up it was we did not do
good but other than that we had a lot of
fun by like cutting vines swinging out
and then falling on the vines and they'd
break and we'd go into the thorn bushes
hahaha
it was great fun but that was like a big
part of my child and just like I love
that environment of it I love I love
being out in nature and I'm not actually
one much for camping but I do love the
idea of hiking out in the woods and and
being out here in California like
California is a big State and it's got a
lot of forests so the farther up north
you go towards Oregon there's just tons
and tons of stuff that you can be doing
in this guy's rock climbing which is so
awesome cuz I love rock till you can't
even see that but my hands on tour know
I should probably put that back because
that's it was back-breaking but you know
anything for the service anytime uh-huh
I sure did good on that whatever the
hell I did is that Yoda or something
what the hell is that it's that Smokey
the Bear spooky spooky oh god geez
what's Oscar fires don't be swimming
naked with fireworks or I'll come find
you okay the forest burns I don't think
there's any fictional character I hate
more than forest burns
yeah well he really freaked me out as a
kid it shrink it did have a field day
with you okay what kind of name is
Forrest burns
anyway yeah well it's still better than
forest burns what did you say about my
name young man
Hank stare into the face of death and
know that all lies in the darkness when
fire consumes all black okay anyway I'm
gonna put forest burns down for a second
there take some of that and you go to
hell I could never but I did not I could
not
so it's just the oh good we're such fast
friends that's good to know I'm gonna
drop this huh boy I throw badly alright
I'm finally back home goody goody
gumdrops hey you keep your lights on at
night that's good to know
we're so bonding oh good a cinder block
maybe I could smash the demon person hey
on the ground outside of my tower ok I
got a cinder block if anyone comes at me
I'll beat your face in with a cinder
block smash it yeah don't mess with me
I'm a wild I should plant I'm gonna
plant forest burns to guard the way
you'll never lose me I'll always be
there with you in the darkest of nights
underneath your bed would you sleep and
guarding you from demons that take your
typewriter
thanks bernzy you're always gonna be the
best of friends with me don't worry
we're always good to be fast friends
fastest of friends I'll get the
typewriter in a second I gotta bring
bernzy back up here he'll scare away
anybody oh gosh that doesn't look good
that looks ransacked someone broke in
they wrecked the place through my
typewriter out the window jeez okay
bernzy you stay right there what the
hell bernzy come on bernzy how do i drop
you nicely
yeah I saw in the canyon but I need you
to feel safe out here yeah just point me
to the Forest Service weapons cache and
I'll feel safer than the Pope and is a
little car no I got forest burns here Oh
God day two did I just sleep it off just
sleep through that what is that what is
that Oh
burnsy we're birds ego wake up what I'm
already with birds II radioing out and
that's not working either
and I go fix it you probably can't but
what you can do is hike out to where the
wire runs through your area and report
back if it's down then I can track down
a ranger to get someone on it I can do
that where is it
no yeah go through it and keep going
straight to the north when you come out
you got a Delilah that's Henry oh yeah I
don't like Hank Thanks I'm writer I
would know and I would know - you'll do
great riding in the darkest nights
thanks God Bernie you're so nice to me
I'm nice to everyone okay all right
thanks Bernie
I'm gonna take you with me you're such a
delight where did Bernie go where's
Bernie you thought I was gone did you
well I can never leave we can never
leave it's getting dark
am I supposed to be going what was my
objective again I have no idea sir
freight communication lines north of the
canyon so I got to go back to where I
came so I'm there I got to get the
communication lines north of the so
Thunder Canyon and then I got to go
north up there there's a bunch of caches
that are marked on my map I've been to
that one see I went down to the lake I
saw them got that cache there I think I
got that cache as well so the cave
that's locked off and it's either wants
me to go to mule point so I guess I
could go ah telephone line so if there's
got to be it's got to be this one
because the telephone line runs through
that so I got a go-to thoroughfare trail
that means that I can hit a cache up
that way I don't know how to get to that
cache over there it must be through the
path off of Thunder Canyon there must be
a way up there I need more rope to do
that so uh as far as I go I go back
towards cave and then I go up north
sounds good to me
I am gonna do that I am gonna do that
way so if I find the outhouse I found
out house that mean I do good and go
where I need go all right off we go into
the land oh yeah more tales from when I
was a kid in the woods one of the most
fun things to do back there was just
playing in the creek and diverting the
creek so we didn't always just pan off
you know horribly we didn't just pan off
all the animals that we saw but we did
enjoy just kind of like feeling like we
were kings and like Lords of the land
and like changing the course of the
river and we just diverted and it only
been like a few feet if anything at all
but it made us feel like we were
incredible and could do anything at all
and that was like such a cool feeling to
know that we could change the course of
things like that and even though it was
small children so it meant a lot to us
and in addition to that like every
single day we would go back out there
and there's actually a funny story it
was the first time that I had been
introduced to the concept of horn was
actually out in those woods I was eight
at the time so I obviously I couldn't
appreciate for any capacity
nothing there's something to appreciate
anyway but it was it was really funny
because my brother and a friend from the
neighborhood were out there and they
found a VHS that was named like I don't
know it's something ridiculous like
backdoor [ __ ] 9
something like that it was obvious what
it was and they knew what it was but I
didn't know what it was so I was just
like oh this is amazing I guess I
suppose this is cool these imagine me as
an 8 year old so they I knew that it was
bad though I knew that we weren't
supposed to have it you know I knew that
it was something that definitely was not
supposed to be in her hands even though
I had no idea what it was at the time so
my brother I and this friend from the
neighborhood we all take it back to the
house we sneak it in like under our
shirts or they're sneaking it in I'm
just worried out of my mind and they
they go down into the basement where we
have a VHS player ok we have a VHS
player but we're little kids and don't
understand the idea that if you're doing
it in the VHS player there's no way that
you could be caught it's not like it's
gonna record exactly what happened so in
our little brains we thought that the
porn the VHS tapes worked like projector
screens you know we'd pull it out and
this is advanced seeking for such young
kids but we pulled like the tape out of
its hold and like stretched it out of
the VHS completely ruining it took a
flashlight and was holding it up to it
like why isn't this working we should
see boobs or something Oh
and so we ruined the entire thing when
we had a VHS right there and we didn't
like and then I was so paranoid I think
I said like we can't do it at the VHS do
something horrible we get caught Oh No
so that was the first time I was ever
produced actually pretty damn cold out
here smoking weed lots of weed
he may have you know I don't know just
used to spend a lot of time with our dog
mayhem uh-huh he was a German Shepherd
big as a truck well we we walked out of
the shelter and there was some graffiti
on a trashcan inant said dick Oh mayhem
and he walked over and peed all over it
and there you go that's a really cute
story it is what it is uh-huh just gonna
keep hiking and hoping it warms up okay
barely she goes I'm absolutely sure
alright I'll let you know if anything
changes in that regard hey sorry about
that anyway I thought about it and that
story is cute and sorry but but you said
we you owned him with someone who was
that I I don't think he has any idea
what was that were you talking about me
what you left your button pressed or
something actually it's not really your
business why are you freaking out I'm
not freaking out oh she's annoyed well
maybe you shouldn't have been talking
about secrets it's not my fault it's not
my fault well that's kind of my fault
yeah that was a little bit douchey of
what I was doing there but but
interestingly enough in my opinion I
don't know if she was talking about me
yeah I guess I should have done that big
I'm a bad boy I'm on bad boy I shouldn't
have been talking about her personal
business if I was gonna creep in on it I
should have just left it alone even
though it did sound a lot like it was
about me and I kind of wanted to know
what it was about if there was something
that I didn't know anyway so let's get
back to where we were poor Delilah I'm
sorry they're just okay so there's a
fork in the path here so there's got to
be sad about that I really do feel bad
about that
nose douchey of me I knew is douchey but
like part of me because I'm playing the
game I'm like I can just save and do it
again but this game I don't even think
you can load it god I've been playing it
for an hour I didn't even realize that I
was playing this game for an hour what
am I gonna end this episode am I gonna
play through the whole game I had no
idea
well that was sad to me I feel I feel
bad I feel like legitimately bad I want
Delilah to talk to me because I'm all
alone in the woods what am I supposed to
do with myself am I supposed to do with
my time Lila I'm sorry I'm sorry I
didn't want to talk about my wife
is this holdout house Delilah hey I
found a structure that might have been
an outhouse once I think you know use
abandoned [ __ ] at your own peril I
mean I'm in the right area all the way
to the top point and if it's not damaged
you can loop around back home I can see
the wire you're talking about it looks
like it's in good shape from here and
I'm sorry I wanna apologize Delilah for
all of my transgressions it would be
really nice if you could say you forgive
me and then we can move on and be
friends because I don't have any friends
out here then there's a crisis and weird
people wandering these woods I don't
like him a lot I guess it'll work out in
the end I'll try not to be a douche to
Delilah but I really really I'm curious
about what she was talking about there
because because if it was about me and
there's some actual dark secret to these
woods even though this is kind of
staying within the realms of reality
here like a lot of this is obviously
still real you know in regards to the
environments and the people maybe
there's something sinister here that
needs to be explored but there's a cache
up here that I'm gonna find but I had
such a cute story that's such a cute
story
alright such a cute story I want to talk
about my dog and my wife who is in
Australia I guess god I totally forgot
that it's still in Australia oh okay
this board it's really interesting
I bet birdy would have something to say
about hey Delilah you want to talk about
this piece of wood I found it's really
good and it forgives me okay six feet
down on it okay so anyway that's pretty
much all I'm gonna play for this episode
of you I didn't expect it but I am
really into this game I feel so bad
about about confronting Delilah about
something that wasn't my big
I feel bad and maybe it was my business
and I'm really engrossed in the story
here so I hope you guys are enjoying it
I am actually going to play this to
completion I want to see the end of this
and I hope you guys do too so thank you
everybody so much for watching I guess
I'll do hour-long episodes for
everything in the series and as always
[Music]